hey 42 here in 1900 all the world's
mathematical knowledge could be written
in about 80 books today it would fill
more than a hundred thousand welcome to
RIF
James Garfield 20th president of the USA
could write Greek with one hand whilst
writing Latin with the other human
saliva contains a painkiller called Opie
often that is six times more powerful
than morphine the platypus and the
Echidna
are the only mammals that could make
their own custard they both lay eggs and
produce milk the Archbishop of Manila
from 1974 to 2003 was called cardinal
sin there is a single mega colony of
ants that spans three continents
covering much of Europe the west coast
of the US and the west coast of Japan a
riot in England and Wales must legally
involve a minimum of twelve people on
the US federal law it's only Free People
and in Nevada only two although slavery
was abolished in the British colonies in
the nineteenth century slavery was not
made a statutory offence in the UK until
the 6th of April 2010 an orange is a
berry but a strawberry isn't a nut is
something tied in a single piece of rope
or line whereas something that joins two
rope together is actually called a bend
Jimmy Carter one sent a jacket to the
dry cleaners with the nuclear detonation
code still in the pocket there is a
glacier called blood falls in Antarctica
that regularly pours out red liquid
making it look like the ice is bleeding
humans have the same number of hair
follicles as chimpanzees in 1715 a group
of Jacobite rebels failed to take
Edinburgh Castle because their rope
ladders were 6 feet too short all polar
bears are Irish they're descended from
brown bears that lived in Ireland over
10,000 years ago in 2007
an American man named Corey Taylor tried
to fake his own death in order to get
out of his cell phone contract without
paying a fee but it didn't work thanks
for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you